today the Night wall show the media
panics is a handful of Libs on Twitter
are briefly suspended one thing we've
learned is that the left really cannot
handle even the smallest dose of its own
medicine which is why we should keep
serving it to them also the word woman
is declared the word of the year a
Christmas themed all ages drag show is
horrifying and shocking even by the
already horrifying and shocking
standards of these kinds of events Trump
unveils his major announcement and a
country star explains why she had no
choice but to divorce her husband after
five years turns out the glitter had
worn off what else are you gonna do but
get divorced all of that and more today
on the Matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
well the lack of a red wave during the
midterms lead to more Reckless spending
by a more emboldened Administration
higher taxes deeper inflation if you're
unsure how the next two years will
unfold talk to Birch gold group about
protecting your savings with gold Birch
gold makes it easy to convert your IRA
or 401K into an IRA and precious metals
so you can own gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account gold is the world's
oldest most proven form of currency when
inflation soars and all other assets go
size sideways gold is still there this
month you can get a free gold back with
every 5 000 purchase when you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into a precious
metals Ira with Birch gold by December
22nd just text Walsh to 98 98 98 Birch
gold will help you own gold and silver
in a tax sheltered account all you got
to do is text Walsh to 98 98 98 to claim
your free info kit on gold and talk to
one of their precious metals Specialists
with every purchase you make before
December 22nd you'll get a free gold
back which I am now holding in my hand
if you didn't notice this is a great
stocking stuffer just just in time for
Christmas text Walsh 298 98 98 and
protect yourself with gold today
we wake up this morning in a shattered
country all is broken All Is Lost we
stagger about traumatized terrified with
glazed eyes and vacant expressions
sifting through the wreckage can we
rebuild
but with what
there is only
debris only the pieces of what once was
we still can't comprehend what we've
experienced what we've
seen we can't confront the horrors that
we all witnessed last night when the
apocalypse came
and a few Libs were temporarily
suspended on Twitter
nothing will ever be the same again
yes if you haven't heard the news by now
as it was reported in screaming
Headlines by NBC News ABC News CNN
Reuters the Associated Press The
Huffington Post USA Today the New York
Times every other corporate media Outlet
a handful of left-leaning journalists
had their Twitter account suspended last
night for a few days among the Fallen
are Vox journalist Aaron rupar who's a
leftist hack known for generating
outrage mobs by disseminating out of
context videos also CNN reporter Donnie
O'Sullivan New York Times Reporter Ryan
Mack Washington Post reporter Drew
Harwell The Intercept journalist Michael
Lee
and then of course blubbering
human-sized wart Keith olberman was also
suspended the media has without a hint
of irony
decried these suspensions and again put
them in there like the leading headline
story on their Publications which were
all passed down at about the same time
last night a kind of red wedding of
Twitter Libs and they're saying that
it's an attack on Free Speech it's an
assault on freedom it's of course a
threat to democracy there have even been
calls for Congressional investigations
into this
many elected Democrats have joined the
outrage Brigade including representative
Dean Phillips who called the suspension
quote antithetical to free speech and a
tactic of the most Disturbed deranged
and destructive men in human history
other Democrats haven't been any less
melodramatic December 15th
yesterday the day of the Twitter
suspensions is the new January 6th and 9
11 combined a day that will live in
infamy in the mines anyway of the
whiniest most self-obsessed overgrown
babies to ever walk the earth
now the reason for the suspensions
um was not simply that these people are
a bunch of blabbering left-wing tools
they did not violate any don't be a
blabbering left-wing tool policy which
still has not been technically added to
the terms of service uh for Twitter
instead as the daily wire explains they
violated the rules against doxing read
it now from the daily wire report it
says Twitter CEO Elon Musk suspended
multiple high-profile left-wing media
figures from the platform Thursday for
violating a rule about posting
information that revealed the location
of his private jet Mike Solana
editor-in-chief of pirate wires wrote on
Twitter so far I've been able to confirm
about half of the account suspended
posted links to the jet tracker thing in
violation of the new doxing policy
unclear just yet about the rest but I
think it's safe to say the rule is for
Real musk responded to Solana Suite by
saying same doxing rules apply to
journalists as to anyone else they
posted my exact real-time location
basically assassination coordinates in
obvious direct violation of Twitter
terms of service must continue
criticizing me all day long is totally
fine but doxing my real-time location
and endangering my family is not he
later added Moss clarified that the
accounts were not permanently banned but
were instead suspended for seven days
the suspensions came after musk
announced a new policy change Wednesday
after an incident happened involving his
child
quote any account doxing real-time
location info if anyone will be
suspended as it is a physical safety
violation this includes posting links to
sites with real-time location info
posting locations someone traveled to on
a slightly delayed basis isn't a safety
problem so it's okay
last night a car carrying Lil X that's
what he calls his child in La was
followed by crazy stalker thinking it
was me who later blocked my car for
moving and climbed onto the hood musk
continues legal actions being taken
against uh this person and organizations
supported harm to my family so to review
um There Are Rules against doxing musk
made it clear that posting real-time
coordinates
um is that counts as doxing
and these accounts did it anyway and so
they were banned or suspended
from what I've read also the exact
coordinates coordinates and real-time
location of his private jet this is not
publicly available information it's
publicly available because they're
posting it in public now but this is
actually private information that
various accounts on Twitter had
you know obtained and had been posting
and passing around
despite the fact that there's obviously
no news value or any legitimate reason
why the public needs to know precisely
where Elon Musk is physically located at
any given moment
it is very clear they were posting the
information to harass and intimidate him
and so they got banned personally my
only complaint against the anti-doxic
rules on Twitter right now is that
they're not strict enough they should be
a whole lot stricter posting real-time
coordinates May count as doxing I
certainly by that argument but it's even
worse to post a person's home address
whether they're currently in their home
or not and yet my home address the
addresses of many other conservative
commentators get posted all the time
Often by accounts who are very explicit
that they are posting it in hopes that
somebody will come and kill us I mean
there's again there's no other reason to
post that but oftentimes they they'll
just come out and say it someone go kill
this person here's this house
and yet in many cases the posts are
allowed to remain up
you could report it and be told that
doesn't violate any policy so hopefully
that will change now with this renewed
focus on getting rid of doxing on the
platform
because yes doxing in any form
should be banned
period
so all that needs to be said here is
that these journalists
broke the rules and faced the penalty
simple as that you know they're treating
this like a traumatic earth-shattering
event because they've never actually
been forced to play by the same rules as
everybody else they've always been given
special treatment they don't know how to
cope or what to do when those privileges
are revoked they can spend years
advocating for rules that everyone else
must follow
but the first time that those standards
are applied to them
they literally call for Congressional
hearings and FBI investigations the EU
has announced that it's considering
sanctions on Twitter for these
suspensions
did they ever do that for conservatives
who are banned
no they they you know the left they they
sick the dogs on us and laugh while we
get Torn to Pieces but then they scream
out in shock and horror when those same
dogs turn back around and start chasing
them not only that
but they expect us
to step in and pull the dogs off of them
they look over to us demanding that we
save them from suffering the faith that
they wanted us to suffer instead
they accuse if they sick the dogs on us
and and uh and then the dogs turn around
they they accuse us of hypocrisy if we
won't save them from the Fate that they
that they wanted us to suffer
and the problem is that too often
conservatives are willing to do just
that conservatives are willing to play
White Knight to the very people who want
them silenced and destroyed
and that's the most important Point here
because for a moment okay this is the
this is the overarching point it goes
beyond Twitter
and for a moment forget about the fact
that the suspensions were perfectly
Justified according to the rules so
forget about that for a second
I'll tell you right now that even before
I found out why they were suspended
I didn't care
you know I wasn't going to run to their
defense regardless of the reason
it could have turned out that they were
suspended just because Elon Musk wanted
to suspend them and and and that just
was annoyed with them and decided to do
it
if that had been his reason I wouldn't
have cared I would not have defended
them
I would have been one of these
conservatives we must stand on principle
and cut run to the defense of Keith
olberman
yeah that's what many conservatives were
doing last night even still today
you can always count on some on the
right to rush to the left defense when
they finally get a dose of their own
medicine no don't hold them to their own
standards we're better than that
we have to be better than that well
if we are better than that we shouldn't
be
okay
This Is War get your head in the game
if you're better than that stop being
better than that
here's what I know
the left laughed and cheered while
conservatives were arbitrarily
de-platformed for years
okay and in many cases people are
getting the platform like these
journalists that work for the Washington
Post in your times whatever they're
gonna be fine
okay they're making money they're gonna
keep making money they're gonna be fine
they still have every other platform
available to them they've got everything
meanwhile you've had conservatives who
they get de-platformed by everything it
ruins their their lives their livelihood
everything is taken away from them
and these same people who are now crying
about getting suspended for a few days
or cheering that along
and and now they cry when they get
de-platformed even for non-arbitrary
reasons
but again even if it was arbitrary
I would not be speaking up in their
defense why
it's very simple because I believe that
you should be held to your own standards
okay that's not hypocrisy
so
when I am held to the left standards I
complain about it I object
because I think that the left standards
are insane and stupid
but they aren't my standards
okay I have every right to object
they're trying to impose something on me
that they came up with
so of course I'm going to object to that
however I do think the left should be
held to their standards because it's
their standards
I don't want to reap what they sow but I
want them to
that's not hypocrisy
that's fairness that's Justice
you sowed it you reap it
it's not up to me to be the one reaping
what you sow
now I'm not calling for leftists to
start getting banned from Twitter and
mass I don't want that mostly because if
they're all gone then there's no one
left to troll and it's not fun anymore
but if it did happen
I make my solemn pledge
that I will not speak up for them any
more than they spoke up for me
and this conservative instinct to rescue
the left from getting hit with their own
boomerangs needs to die
it needs to stop
okay if somebody on that side gets
de-platformed after spending years
trying to de-platform and destroy you
all you need to say to them is hey
freedom of speech has a freedom from
consequence right isn't that what you've
always said
anyway bye
that's all
is that hypocritical on our part does it
show that we lack principles
no it is perfectly consistent
perfectly principled
make them live and die by the rules they
have set
there is nothing more consistent than
that
again it's called Justice it's called
fairness
one other point for the record and this
is important also
my primary objection to the D
platforming of conservatives
is not
that it violates free speech that's not
my primary objection
okay
but rather that conservatives were
de-platformed and are still
de-platformed
for saying true and correct things okay
we have been banned for saying things
like trans women are men uh and uh and
you know the vaccines don't stop the
spread
and many other statements just as
accurate as those
the reason why it's so orwellian and
oppressive and bad to ban people for
saying such things is not simply that
people have the right to express
themselves but even more so that the
truth should not be suppressed
the left doesn't merely ban Free Speech
it bans the truth
which is much worse
the same thing I say about college
campuses trying to keep conservatives
off college campuses I get protested on
college campuses when I'm there you know
the what is a woman tour
okay my objection to that is not just we
need for open Dialogue on college campus
we do need open dialogue but it's worse
than that
because I'm not just saying anything
I I'm I'm saying things that are
objectively correct and true and that's
what they're protesting
and that makes it so much worse
and so when someone on that side is
banned or censored or whatever
it is automatically not the same as when
someone on the other side is banned
because people on our side are banned
for saying what is true
and while we can have a conversation
about what sort of speech should be
prohibited on social media platforms
what I know for sure is that the truth
should never be prohibited anywhere
now I personally am in favor of allowing
all content on social media except for
uh doxing death threats and porn okay if
it's up to me those are the rules and
they're very simple
everything is allowed but you can't dox
you can't issue death threats and you
can't post porn
that would be the rule if it was up to
me
I think all opinions outside of those
which those things are not opinions
anyway should be allowed but my point is
that there is no moral equivalence here
because the campaign of censorship that
conservatives have endured for years has
really been a campaign of Truth
suppression
and that is how we should refer to it
so while we laugh righteously at the
libs who are banned and we enjoy the
spectacle of them
clumsily trying to walk around with the
shoe finally on the other foot
that's the thing that we should keep in
mind
now let's get to our five headlines
women love getting new pajamas at
Christmas time Pajamagram I don't know
how pronounce them is it pajama or
pajama so I'm just gonna rotate between
the two makes it really easy for us man
this year I'm getting my wife a set of
pajamas from their naturally nude line
the texture and feel of these pajamas is
so silky and smooth that I know she's
going to love them if you have no idea
what to get your girlfriend or your wife
this year trust me she wants these
pajamas but you need to order today
because last year they sold out before
Christmas order today and Pajamagram
will include a free matching naturally
nude nightie with your order that's 75
in savings on their best-selling holiday
gift Pajamagram offers free gift
packaging so your present comes ready to
put under the tree you don't have to do
any work at all go to pajamagram.com
right now order the naturally nude
pajamas that's pajamagram.com for
naturally nude pajamas don't forget to
tell them Matt sent you
all right big news to start with from
CNN woman is dictionary.com's word of
the year a word so simple and so common
but nonetheless according to the site
Inseparable from the story of 2022 this
year's pick is a reflection of the
ongoing cultural conversations around
gender identity and language now people
turn the dictionary to make sense of
these complex issues the online
reference side said in Tuesday's now
announcement this year the very matter
of the definition of the word woman was
at the center of so many consequential
moments discussions and decisions in our
society John Kelly dictionary.com senior
director of editorial said a news
release our selection of women as the
word of the year and how the word is
defined who is included in that
definition and who the word applies and
belongs to Highlights how important the
work of a dictionary is and how
dictionaries can impact people's lives
um
now
first of all it is it's interesting that
woman is the word of the year
when
you know uh
it's what's happened to the word woman
this year and years prior is that
there's been an attempt to abolish it
get rid of it get rid of the of its of
its meaning which is the same thing as
getting rid of the word but it will not
surprise you to learn that neither the
announcements from dictionary.com nor
the CNN article nor I imagine any other
article that mentions that you know this
this thing acknowledges
me or the film what is a woman
but even so
like we know that we are the reason why
woman is the word of the year okay
everyone knows that
just like what is a woman
of course is going to be left off has
been left off every year-end list of
best films of the Year even though it is
now I know I'm biased but it's also just
objectively true it's one of the best
films and most influential films of the
year and one of the most influential
important documentaries of the century
um
but it's uh it's they're not going to
acknowledge that and that's okay
because the effect the impact of uh the
work that we've done and the content we
put out is being acknowledged
and you know in a in a way I mean even
though there's this irony in the fact
that uh it's a word of the Year even
though it's like the word that was
abolished this year
um
it is it is a it's a reflection of the
of the importance of of
of that work all right
so an independent journalist named
Taylor Hansen reports on
and we've seen a lot of these
unfortunately
but this one
this one still somehow shocked me this
is a an all ages drag show another one
this is in Austin Texas it's a Christmas
themed drag show a show that's
apparently touring through 18 different
states 36 different shows this month
um and I can't even show you most of the
videos and images he posted
yeah I mean suffice it to say that they
are just blatantly sexual even more so
than some of the other footage that
we've seen no mistake we're talking
about barely clothed performers
simulating sex acts on each other on
stage talking graphically about sex
um
a explicitly sexual performance with
kids in the audience kids who are
invited because this was advertised as
an all age distraction
so here's actually we'll play One Clip
this is one of the Tamer Clips this is
one of the clips that we that I can play
and even this it has to be bleeped and
censored and all the rest of it and
remember there are young children in the
in the audience and this deviant
scumbag who you're going to see here is
actually at one point talking to a young
child in the audience uh anyway here it
is
oh wow oh I'm feeling Moody tonight I'm
so happy to be here thank you also for
coming out oh my God so many of you oh
I'm so excited hello are you reaching
for my day hungry
[Applause]
trust me the milk's gone bad you don't
want this milk I know when I've been on
tour we've been on the tour bus I've
been unrefrigerated thank you so
gym I'm gonna put this to good use I'm
gonna buy more breasts and more no I
brought for you some of my best breasts
I brought for you my grandmother's
breasts
yes hand it down to me generation to
generation oh my God hello gray sexy
beautiful nice to see you I had the best
time today with gray and Weston in the
glass coffins
well if you have it you go check it out
they asked me do you want to see the
haunted section I was like hello
do I want to see the whole section I
feel like I am a haunted section I said
let's go
no but I've been having the best time
turning around I've been working so hard
I've actually worked my butthole right
off look at that
look at that
gone don't cry sir don't cry
okay so he uh
yes he did show off his bare butt to the
audience there when he said that and uh
and earlier in the clip was talking to a
child
saying are you hungry in reference to
his fake breasts that he was shown off
there
uh
I I'm at a point now I'm almost like a
single issue voter on this it's not the
only issue but it's the litmus test it's
a perfect litmus test
and I'm not I I
don't want to vote for anyone we get
into 2024
I'm not going to vote for you unless you
promised me that
like that sort of scene
that you're going to be sending federal
agents into there
to arrest every adult
in attendance every adult in attendance
and every adult on stage
okay I want I want I want law
enforcement agents running up onto that
stage
tackling that piece of garbage that scum
dragging him off the stage by his feet
while he's in handcuffs that's what I
want
I'll vote for any presidential candidate
who promises that
what you need to understand here is that
we are dealing with with
pure evil this is pure evil the people
who are doing this
are evil
the people that are that are attending
it
and the people who support it
everything I know people don't you don't
want to think this way about your fellow
Americans especially if you go online
you see the number of of just seemingly
normal Americans who will defend this
and you think I can't believe that there
are so many evil people in this country
there are
and they are evil people
who we should
not want to compromise with not want to
reach an understanding
I don't want to be nice and polite with
you and
I'm not going to say well we disagree on
these issues but we can still be nice to
each other I don't want to be nice to
you
I don't want to be around you
I want nothing to do with you I don't
want to share a country with you I don't
want to share a planet with you that's
how much I despise everything you
represent
so with this this is not compromise okay
all we can do with this is crush it
destroy it
that's what you do with evil
and that's what we have to do with this
that should be our objective
because this is very plainly
the mass sexual abuse of kids
happening in plain sight
and they're not sorry and they're not
ashamed and they're not ever going to
stop until they're made to stop
by the way glad uh tweeted this a couple
days ago
drag phobia is on the rise there's clear
and present danger against our community
and threats I really haven't seen it at
this level in over a decade if ever
that's quoting a drag queen
there's people are angry at our
community
well yeah your your sexually grooming
children in front of everyone people
tend to get mad about that that's right
I can't believe this
I can't believe it
we can't prance around uh on stage half
naked in front of kids without people
getting upset
you know it as I've been saying all
along
you could J here's an idea to the quote
drag queen community
it's not a real community
the fact the fact that you all have a
thing for wearing women's clothes that
doesn't make you a community it's not a
community
um but here's an idea
if you don't like the reaction you're
getting from the public maybe just stop
doing that how's that for an idea stop
doing it
none of this backlash is happening
none of this uh uh
scrutiny is being directed at you guys
if you aren't doing this
keep the kids out of it you perverts
keep them out of it and there's no
problem
nobody was talking about drag drags
existed for a long time no one was
talking about it until you start
involving kids and that's when it became
an issue have you noticed the connection
keep the kids out of it
and no one cares
you want to go to your gay clubs or
whatever and do your uh your your drag
your your dumb drag shows with just a
bunch of adults
no I don't want to see it no one wants
to talk about it nobody cares
you bring kids into it and now it's a
problem
stop doing that and it's not a problem
anymore
so I mean just think about this
if it's true
that they're in fear for their lives and
they're getting all these threats and
everything and most of this is just
invented and made up
and even if it's true and and so
according to you you're getting threats
and all that because of uh you're
exposing kids to drag and you're still
doing it
so what like it's this important you're
going to risk your life
to expose children to drag that's how
important it is to you
to use the phrase It's always her like
me this is the hill you're gonna die on
foreign just makes me all the more
determined to oppose you
drag phobia they say
um
first of all it's not phobia
it's uh drag I don't know drag disgust
drag nausea one of those words not
phobia
you don't scare me
I'm scared on behalf of the kids I'm
scared for the kids they're being
exposed to this stuff
and the effect it's going to have on
them
but no no no no one's afraid of you
know you don't scare anybody
a bunch of men in women's clothes
dancing around the stage I think that
you think that scares us
they try to have a belt both ways I
still terrified these people are they're
being so mean to us and they're afraid
of us which is it
but drag phobia so now that we have the
phobia attached to it uh that is now
confirmation that the the
metaphomorphosis is complete and now
drag queen has become its own identity
okay that's this is this is the final
step in uh in in inducting a you know
bringing a new identity into the fold
baptizing christening a new identity the
final step is to give it to give it its
own phobia
and as soon as that happens now drag
queens are their own idea I guarantee
you and this is I'm not saying this is a
joke it in very short order they're
going to add D for drag queen to the
LGBT alphabet soup it's going to be in
there they're going to get their own
they're gonna get their own stripe on
the uh on the increasingly cluttered
pride flag all that's being added in as
its own thing its own identity
and we knew that was happening too
because you see how even you know media
articles to talk about the drag queens
they always refer to the drag queens
with if you notice with the female
pronouns as if they actually are I mean
they are men performing as women
and yet
it's when we talk about them we're
supposed to talk about them as if their
characters are real and they really are
women
that's because it's finally changed over
now and drag queen is an identity and
the reason why they're making the shift
is that once they call something an
identity then you can't criticize it now
if it's just a hobby if it's just a
fetish if it's just a recreation if it's
just something like this
then you can criticize that all day long
it was just a profession you know you
can criticize that but identities you
can't criticize
and so how do they take something take a
fetish take something and put it make it
above criticism just say that it's
identity
unfortunately I don't play along with
those rules I don't care if you call it
Identity or not
I'm still going to criticize it
all right
this is from daily wire former president
Donald Trump teased a huge announcement
this week but uh when it turned out to
be a limited run of digital trading
cards featuring Trump's face on the
bodies of superheroes hilarity ensued on
Twitter the former president teased the
news in a video showing himself with
lasers coming from his eyes claiming
that America needs a superhero he then
made the official announcement via's
platform truth social declaring the
release of a limited series of trump
digital trading cards that were very
much like a baseball card but hopefully
much more exciting
only 99 each for the digital trading
cards yeah this was announced two days
ago uh that he had a major announcement
people were talking about what could the
announcement be some people speculated
maybe he's announcing his a VP selection
maybe something like that and um uh I
was skeptical that it would be anything
you know actually exciting like that and
it turns out that it was the digital
trading card so so Trump is selling nfts
now so that's what that is
and he did now the full story is that on
the same day a few hours after releasing
the nfts he also announced a serious
policy proposal that's quite good it's
his Free Speech policy proposal to
combat big Tech censorship and it's
focused largely on I mean there are
multiple sort of platforms uh or pillars
to this platform but it's largely
focused on prohibiting government
agencies from interfering on these
platforms so we're not going to have
another Hunter Biden's laptop
sort of situation
which is a good idea and uh and it's
something that should be done and Trump
if he's president again I really hope
that he does it
and there are some Trump fans who are
claiming that the major announcement he
teased was actually this and so this is
all the false narrative that it wasn't
no he wasn't talking about the digital
trading cards he was talking about this
except the problem is that he teased a
major announcement quote unquote with a
picture of him as a superhero and then
the next day unveil the nfts calling it
a major announcement and selling images
of him as a superhero so it's you can't
get around the fact that that's what he
was talking about
or I mean either he meant
either he meant the nft thing to be the
major announcement or he didn't and he
meant for the policy approach will be
major announcement but for some damn
reason unveiled the nfts First with the
phrase major announcement attached to
them
and so it was the clumsiest most
self-defeating policy rollout of all
time I mean in other words either he
stomped all over his own policy rollout
on purpose or by accident
he stole his own Thunder purposely or or
or
you know unintentionally either way it's
like it's just a kind of unforced error
that you shouldn't be making when you've
been in the game this long
and have already been president
and it makes me again it makes me wonder
like who who is around Trump at this
point that has good political instincts
and can
would be able to step in in a situation
like this and say no hang on a second
don't don't
you know you just announced your
campaign don't announce a bit a major
announcement and then come out with an
nft like don't do that you want to have
the nft I mean I I don't think you
should have the nfts at all because nfts
are a scam but you want to do that just
you know just put them out there you
don't need to
why is there no one around Trump who can
tell him that
is there anyone left who can or will
say it
the other issue here is is with the
policy proposal itself I mean it's a
good policy I like it but the problem
politically is that uh Trump needs to
convince the electorate particularly you
know in in a primary if he does have a
serious primary challenge
he needs to convince them that he will
actually do these things and uh in order
to convince us he also needs to explain
why he didn't do them or anything like
it the first time around I mean the
Republicans owned
the White House and Congress for two
years
and
there was no serious effort to uh you
know
get a get a grip on big Tech or any of
these kinds of issues
I don't put that entirely on Trump like
I said Republicans owned the White House
and Congress but
they didn't do any of this they didn't
do much I mean they they passed the tax
cut
and that was about it
so this is this is a hurdle you're gonna
have to get over and that's he's gonna
be he's gonna be uh
susceptible that and vulnerable to that
especially in the primary if he's
getting attacked from the right now I
think
best case scenario politically for Trump
is that in a primary there will be some
kind of primary challenge
we know that but um
best case scenario for him is that in
the Republican primary he only gets
attacked from the left which is
basically what happened in 2016. it's
you know all of his Republican
challenges are attacking from the left
or they were attacking him just a bit on
style points or saying that he's being
too mean the mean tweets and all that if
that's if that's all he gets then he'll
Coast to Victory
um on the other hand what has never
really happened to him and didn't happen
in 2016 is is it is an attack from the
right
of somebody saying
you're not going far enough or you
didn't do enough or you know here's what
I did to advance this kind of
conservative policy and you didn't do
that's the kind of thing he never had
and so it remains to be seen how he'll
respond to that
all right
um
what else do we got here how much time
do we have okay
this one the daily wire says film
director Darren Aronofsky is defending
his choice to cast actor Brendan Fraser
to play an obese gay man in the Golden
Globe nominated drama the whale the
movie tells a story of Charlie a
middle-aged man who gains weight
following the death of his boyfriend and
works on repairing the relationships
with his estranged daughter it received
critical Acclaim but one common reaction
in the Hollywood Community was to
question whether Frasier was the best
choice for the role given that he's not
actually gay or obese
Aronofsky said he was surprised by the
reaction but still stands behind his
decision
he said the film director said actors
have been using makeup since the
beginning of acting that's one of their
tools and the lengths we went to portray
the realism of the makeup has never been
done before one of my first calls after
casting Brendan was to my makeup artist
I asked him can we do something that
realistic because it's going to look
like a joke if it's going to look like a
joke then we shouldn't do it
this is the kind of thing I was I was I
was wait when I heard this about this
film was coming out and it is getting
some some awards buzz and some some
critical acclaim
and I thought like are they actually
going to be able to get away with this
now I have no issue with it
and it sounds like an interesting idea
uh put take Brendan Fraser uh and put
him in like in the fat suit and try to
pull off an actual dramatic performance
sounds interesting to me
and I'll probably give it a watch when
it uh when it's available on streaming
but I was wondering can't are can are
can you get away with this now are you
allowed to even do this
because he's not actually morbidly obese
so they'll put him in the fat suit
and then I didn't even realize until I
just read the article but apparently
he's portraying a gay man
and he's not gay
so not only do you have the
appropriation claim but then also is it
it's uh is it is it body shaming you
know because if you're going to have a
dramatic story about a morbidly obese
person
a lot of the drama is going to be
grounded in the fact that it's not
good to be morbidly obese like this is
something that he's suffering with this
I would think that that's how it's
portrayed it's not it's not gonna be
portrayed like he's not gonna be dancing
to lizzo's songs the whole the whole
film okay he's not going to be giving I
I assume he's not going to be giving
speeches on uh body acceptance and fat
acceptance and all the rest of it
so can you do that in modern Hollywood
and it turns out
maybe sort of but not really
because the backlash I guess it took a
little bit while for the backlash to
generate but now it's finally here and
of course it's completely ridiculous
I mean the the value if there's any
value to acting as an art form
and I think there is by the way
you know when it's done well it is it is
a true art form and uh it's it can be a
very powerful art form
but I think one of the things again when
done well one of the things that makes
it so powerful is that it's uh it's
it's empathy you know acting is it's
almost empathy as an art form
because you you have to inhabit someone
else who isn't you and
you know sort of try to understand their
motivations and and inhabit that
character I don't know I'm not an actor
myself but that seems like that's kind
of the process
which is why for so long before we got
into this obsession with with
appropriation and representation all
this nonsense
it's
usually the critically acclaimed
performances are the ones that where an
actor is portraying something that's
much further away from who he actually
is
that's that's when you're the most
impressed
you're not impressed with the fact that
an actor is portraying something very
similar to what they already are
there might be a certain skill involved
in that but when you could put an actor
in a role that's the total opposite of
of them
and they pull it off
then that's the whole art that's what
the that's what the art is
and it's a good thing because it's it's
empathy to put Brendan Fraser in a fat
suit and have him really pull off that
performance
and uh turn them into a protagonist that
you kind of feel for and root for
um that shows that he has empathy he's
understanding people who struggle with
obesity
so it should be something that we
celebrate but oftentimes it's not all
right let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know for something that actually
relieves your nausea which is something
I'm I've I was always looking for with
struggling with nausea and cars and car
sickness until I finally found relief
band relief band is the number one FDA
cleared anti-nausea wristband clinically
proven to quickly and effectively
prevent or relieve nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness and
chemotherapy whether you need everyday
nausea relief or an occasional cure
you've got to check out relief band like
the name says relief band is
legitimately a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea you
can even change the intensity depending
on how you're feeling relief band has a
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau and over 100 000 satisfied
customers if you want if you want the
band that actually works to relieve your
nausea you got to check out relief band
if I've worked out an exclusive offer
just for my listeners if you go to
reliefband.com use promo code Walsh you
get 20 off plus free shipping any no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use promo code
Walsh for 20 percent off
Jessica hartsell says yesterday I
listened to a handful of your old
episodes from three or four years ago
and one of those episodes you discussed
capital punishment and claim to Waffle
on the subject not firmly on one side or
the other today's episode bring back
public execution LOL I agree with
today's view yeah I've uh I've been
pretty open about that that I've I've
kind of been
on both sides of the issue and for a
while I waffled on and I wasn't exactly
sure
um but in recent years I've come much
more firmly down on the side of
of being in favor of capital punishment
and and uh
you know advocating for public execution
by the way I don't think that that's
yeah I've always felt that if you're
going to have it like if you're gonna
have if there's an argument for it then
uh there's also an argument for having
public executions because part of the
value of having that it's not the only
thing but uh it is there's the
deterrence element
and that will help with the deterrence
and I think it also is it's it's Justice
I actually think that you know
if you're going to do this
and you're gonna you're gonna pass down
the ultimate penalty which is to take
someone's life
which I am in favor of
for crimes that warrant it because I
think there are crimes where there just
is no other
way of addressing it there's there's no
other response that makes any sense
um but if you're going to do it then I
do think it should be in public I I
think the idea of kind of
the state just taking someone to a back
room somewhere at the prison and maybe
there are a few witnesses there but no
one really sees it and just dispatching
of them
um I think that's a lot worse than doing
it in public and letting people see
this is what's happening here's what's
happening to this person
and here's why it's happening
now we got nothing to hide
you know we're we're also not going to
hide from the fact we're not going to
try to execute somebody in a way that
kind of sanitizes it or medicalizes it
we gotta inject poison to make it look
like they're just getting a you know
they're just going to the doctor getting
shot uh no we are we are killing them
this is what's happening it is a violent
act and we are in fact killing someone
and we're going to do it in a way that
does not hide from that fact because
that's what it is so all right
Scott says Matt your wife might actually
be a bigger troll than you step up your
Troll game man
Erica says Matt's facial being handed a
teddy bear scarf and subsequently
serenaded by an Elvis impersonator wins
the internet today
Kara says Elvis serenading Matt was the
best thing I've seen on The Daily wire
we need a sequel
Walsh's wife is the ultimate I do
believe there was a moment when Matt was
second guessing taking the walrus home
Ruth says Matt be honest the Elvis
moment was staged
Kim Matt what happened to the Elvis clip
you took it out wanted to show my
husband so disappointed okay
so to address the Elvis in the room um
it was not staged not at all I would
never be involved in staging such a
thing you guys know me I like if they'd
ask me I would have said no I don't want
any part of that so this was entirely my
wife's idea in doing she dreamed this up
in her Twisted little head and it was a
plan
perfectly calibrated to annoy me from
every possible angle
and as far as that goes it was it I I
mean I have to admit it was brilliant I
didn't want to say that to her I didn't
want to give her the satisfaction
and when I saw her later that night and
she was like oh yeah she was so proud of
herself I wasn't going to give her that
credit but you know don't tell her I
said this but it was it was uh it was a
work of Evil Genius and uh I had
begrudging respect for an emphasis on
begrudging now the plan did have one
flaw though she was so focused on
whether she should troll me with an
Elvis impersonator she never stopped to
think about whether she could
legally according to copyright policy so
sadly she didn't obtain the necessary
clearances to have those songs performed
and so it had to be taken down so
otherwise the YouTube would take the
whole show down and we get sued or
whatever so
wasn't that was not my call I promise
you that it wasn't my doing I love my
wife I
know how proud she was of this
rightfully so I would have left it up
but it was out of my hands as for uh
Revenge
I I sort of got some last night but I
pulled my punch a little bit because my
wife was texting me while I was still at
work and uh she had suddenly become
concerned that the The Producers may
have gotten in trouble for this whole
stunt like she thought of that after the
fact and so she was texting me about it
you know is everything okay nobody's in
trouble are they and at first I was
going to respond by saying what do you
mean everything's fine no one cares but
then I thought about it and so I texted
back and I said I don't know um Sean
just got called into Jeremy's office I
don't know what's going on I don't know
and she started freaking out and she was
like what oh no and uh and I didn't
respond for a while let it just kind of
linger and then a few minutes later I
text again and I said yeah he just
walked his car I think he was in tears
yeah he didn't say anything to me I
don't know what's going on and then she
called me up and she was panicking and
she felt very guilty and that's when I
I I could have gone for the I could have
gone all the way there and and really
sold it but that's when I I pulled back
because I'm I'm a man of Mercy
ultimately so I admitted that I was
just making them so that means that the
Revenge that there still has to be
Revenge that didn't count that was only
that was only half that was a half
measure
so
to be continued
um
crocodile Grundy says
I told people back in the late 1990s
when political correctness and hate
speech laws were becoming common that
those things would be the death of free
speech I was told that I was a
conspiracy theorist well here we are I
guess we need to start calling
everything they say about us hate speech
it's no different than what we're saying
about them
right and you can't there's there's no
version of
free speech that can exist
while you still have policies and laws
against hate speech
like if if Free Speech means anything if
the person ever means anything it exists
specifically to defend and the kind of
speech that would be labeled hate speech
that's what you need free speech for is
to defend I'm not the first person to
point this out as I point out so many
times this this it exists to defend the
sort of speech that people don't like
and makes people angry you don't you
don't need free speech policies or a
First Amendment or anything to defend
speech that everyone agrees with that's
that you're always going to be fine in
any kind of society saying things that
are acceptable and mainstream it's the
things that people don't like that make
people angry that you need that for and
finally Kelsey says Matt does the SBG
know that you admitted to crying
recently why isn't this big news Matt
Walsh cried he's a crier he cried like a
baby okay more disinformation here I did
not admit to crying this was during all
access last night a lot a lot it was a
weird day yesterday a lot of weird
things happened and I mentioned how
recently the weekend before we had we
took the kids to a restaurant for dinner
and we got Sushi as an appetizer because
my kids like sushi for some reason and
my son dared me to eat a whole giant
tablespoon of Wasabi all at once and so
I did because I was dared and then my
eyes started to water which is a normal
physiological reaction to something like
that
and I my eyes are watering and then my
daughter
pointed at me and said wow look daddy is
crying I've never seen daddy cry before
and she was thrilled to see this
no my eyes are watering okay this isn't
it's not the same there's a distinction
okay fine distinction between eyes
watering and crying this is not you
seeing me cry for the first time you
will eventually see that
um everyone can tell a story about the
the one time they saw their dad cry it's
a big moment
in your life maybe it's when I walk you
down the aisle years from now maybe
that'll be the time
but it's not this you are not going to
tell my grandchildren that this was the
time when you saw
you know Grandpa cry for the first time
it was because of wasabi just for the
record
this year is a big one for me my
documentary what is a woman expose the
effects of corrosive gender ideology our
rally to end child mutilation as leading
to very real actions on the part of
Tennessee legislators all of this was
accomplished despite the wicked forces
that are trying to silence me and all of
us and all this was accomplished largely
in part because of those of you who
joined the fight and I thank you for it
this holiday season you can save 30
percent on new daily wire plus annual
memberships and gift memberships when
you use code holiday at checkout if you
haven't joined the fight yet to be a
part of this team now is the time if
you're already a member we thank you if
you're not yet a member now is the time
to join I'm planning to have an even
bigger year in 2023 uh so you don't want
to sit on the sidelines and miss out go
to dailywire.com Walsh shoes code
holiday at checkout to get 30 off new
daily wire plus memberships that's
dailywire.com Walsh today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
foreign
cancellation today we must cancel a
woman named Kelsey ballerini who I'm
told is a country star I know nothing
about her music but I do know everything
I need to know about her personally
based on a conversation she recently had
during an episode of a podcast called
tell me about it with Jade Iovine now as
reported by the daily wire ballerina
spent uh ballerini rather spent some
time during the interview explaining her
reasons for divorcing her husband singer
Morgan Evans and they just got divorced
after five years of marriage now the
brief clip of this exchange which we
will play for you now
could be an extremely valuable tool
especially for young couples okay in
fact young people in dating
relationships they ask me all the time
how they can know if they've selected
the right partner for marriage right
that's the big question well here's one
way this is a good litmus test sit your
girlfriend down or your boyfriend down
play the following clip for them and
then ask if they agree with the
attitudes and perspectives they hear in
it
and if the answer is anything but oh
hell no are you kidding me
run don't walk run in the other
direction and never look back
so with that setup here it is
is this person right for me like am I
good with this being forever is am I
good with him never doing the dishes
ever in my life you know for the rest of
my life or whatever those stupid things
are how did you know that it wasn't
relationship anxiety or negative
intrusive voices in your head and that
it was actually like your heart speaking
that's a good question
I'm really like intuitive and in tune
with myself and like my gut and my heart
and I think for a while you're right it
was kind of like okay this is just a new
phase of a relationship because
relationships go through Seasons right
and like yes it's not always going to be
rainbows and butterflies like that's
just not it and I and I think for a long
time
I I was like oh this is just
the glitter wears off that's what
happens you know and then you just you
get into a phase where you just you wait
for you wait for it to come back and
then
you know and then sometimes it doesn't
but at the end of the day it is such a
disservice and a dishonoring of yourself
if you know something is not right and
you stay but your life is so loud you
know you have so much going on all the
time
I think when people hear about couples
counseling than they hear about a couple
getting divorced they're like oh it
didn't work but oftentimes that is
actually couples counseling working you
know but like because it you realize
that like this was this isn't the
relationship for both of you and I think
what's so hard is having to break your
own heart and someone else's in the
process of saving yourself
so hard
okay so the glitter wore off after five
years and then uh Kelsey patient woman
that she is waited around for a phase to
see if the glitter returned but to her
heart it never did she must have spent
hours maybe even days potentially a week
waiting to see if the magical marriage
glitter would fall from the sky but it
didn't and she doesn't want to be in a
non-glittering marriage who would uh
indeed she says that it would be
dishonoring and a disservice to herself
if she were to honor her marriage vows
and remain loyal to the man that she
pledged her undying love and Devotion to
but who cares about things like vows and
Oaths and everything else I mean think
about the glitter that's what matters
so she got up and left of course the
other woman in the exchange Jade fully
understands and agrees with this
approach to the marriage Sacrament in
fact she adds that um this is one of the
great benefits of marriage counseling is
that so often as she explains it can
help you to understand that you need to
leave your spouse
after all if you aren't happy then what
else is there to do you just have to
leave
do one more glitter check before you
head out the door stop for a moment look
around do you see any glitter no well
then that's it time to go
like I said play that clip for the PIP
the person you're dating if they roll
their eyes and scoff and say something
like who are these dumb bimbos you know
you found yourself a keeper but if they
listen intently and nod their heads and
say wow yeah glitter in the marriage
that makes some good points
promptly get up
inform the person the relationship is
over and just leave no need for a long
emotional conversation simply end it now
before this person ruins your life
because they will
now here's the issue with um
the marital insights offered by Kelsey
and Jade
well there are many issues but it's a
Friday I don't want to be here all day
so let's uh we'll boil down to just a
few
what we heard In that clip is is the
very common and very wrong uh passive
view of marriage and romance it's the
idea
that your relationship with your spouse
is fueled by some sort of mysterious
emotional Force which is often
incorrectly called love and that as soon
as your marriage runs out of this
mystical fuel all you can do is abandon
it on the side of the road and hitch a
ride with the next car that happens to
drive by
this view is popular in our society
because it removes all responsibility
and all blame from the individual
marriage is presented as a passive
Endeavor it's something that's
established something that's and then
destroyed by forces outside of our
control
love is something that you fall into
right like a puddle and then out of and
there's not much you can really do to
call it to cause the one to prevent the
other
we chalk it up to irreconcilable
differences it's all just stuff that
happens oops I'm married oops I'm having
an affair oops I'm divorced oops I'm
married again oops I'm divorced again
oops I'm lonely and isolated and
everyone I've ever known resents me oops
silly me I'm so clumsy
but here's the reality these were
choices every step of the way and the
state which you find yourself in
falling in and out of this is not love
because Real Love is an act of will it's
a decision it's a conscious activity
it's something that you do
it's something that you live
okay love is chosen
and if it's protected and nurtured it
grows love is sacrifice love is effort
Love is Everything Saint Paul describes
in First Corinthians love is dying to
yourself love is is many things and none
of them happen by accident
but most of all it's a thing you do it
is an activity
so if you stop loving your spouse after
five years it's because you chose to
stop and most likely you never started
the fundamental confusion is that people
think
that emotional infatuation
that they feel for someone that they
first met is love you know that's what
they think they might even describe this
as falling in love or love at first
sight
but infatuation is not love infatuation
actually has almost nothing to do with
love you can be infatuated with somebody
and not love them okay a stalker can be
infatuated with somebody and then kill
them okay I'm not saying that the
infatuation phase is bad I'm simply
saying that it's a phase
um it happens at the very beginning it's
the fuel that's supposed there's a
there's a reason for it it has a it has
a a function and the infatuation phase
it's supposed to help launch the rocket
and get it off the ground but it's not
going to sustain you for the whole
journey or even for any significant part
of it
because infatuation has to give way to
love which isn't to say
that love is less exciting or less
intense or less thrilling quite the
opposite in fact infatuation is fleeting
it's thin it's hormonal
uh love is much realer it's much deeper
it's much more meaningful
I love my wife today
in spite of the Elvis incident after 11
years of marriage in a way that I could
never have loved her when I first met
her I didn't know her when we first met
only thing I knew when we first met is
that she's hot and she has a fun
personality which was more than enough
to be infatuated with okay it doesn't
take much to be infatuated that's and
that's really
especially if you're a guy that's like
all it takes you don't even need the
personality part it's just just the
first part really all you need but
that's not love
um so Kelsey when she talks about the
glitter
what she's really describing is the
infatuation phase but it's all she ever
had with her husband and once it died
rather than work towards a truly loving
and self-sacrificial marriage she just
bailed
many such cases
of course the other problem with this
approach aside from the fundamental
misunderstanding about the nature and
meaning of Love is that it's entirely
self-centered if you know if your own
immediate and uninterrupted happiness is
the focal point of your marriage it will
fail
and there's nothing unique about that
literally any Endeavor will fail if your
immediate and uninterrupted happiness is
the focal point
you will never be able to do anything
worthwhile in Life or achieve anything
of note ever
if you insist that the whole point of
the Enterprise is for you to Simply Be
Happy
okay if the only thing you care about is
your own happiness you will never do
anything worthwhile in your life you
will be a failure you'll be a miserable
failure for your entire life you will
live a pathetic meaningless life and you
will die and nobody will will even
remember that you existed if you live
entirely pursuing your own happiness and
nothing else
now the irony is that Kelsey
is is apparently a successful musician
which means that she understands this
point she has certainly had to Wade
through many unhappy moments in order to
have a success in her music career
nobody can achieve anything notable in
any career if their own happiness is
their sole motivation and goal
I don't know anything about her music I
don't know if it's any good or not but I
mean I suspect it's probably not but but
uh but either way you just it's you
can't become a very successful musician
uh without working really hard it's just
impossible
so if if we can see why that would be
the case in a career
why is it so difficult to see how it
would apply to other areas of your life
that that's not to say that happiness is
irrelevant or unimportant in a marriage
it's just to say that marriage
doesn't exist simply to make you happy
that's not the primary function of a
marriage
it's not the primary function of your
spouse
okay it's not your spouse's job to make
you happy every second of the day it's
not anyone's job to do that
there is no one on this Earth who exists
scratch it there is no one who who
exists in the entire universe
and whose only job is to make you happy
that doesn't that's that doesn't exist
anywhere
it's not anyone's job to do that
and so it's not fair to put that burden
on your spouse especially since the sort
of people who expect others to make them
happy all the time are also the sorts of
people who are never happy
which means that you have given your
spouse a literally impossible job
that you will then blame them for
failing to accomplish
all of that is wrong
and if it was just Kelsey ballerini who
had these uh misconceptions about
marriage it wouldn't even be worth
addressing but tragically these
misconceptions are shared by many in our
culture and it's why so many marriages
fail and uh and so many others never
even begin
and that's why it's still worth saying
today unfortunately Kelsea ballerini is
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of the shows move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]